we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p hears a
voice mail about non-voters hi David I'm
62 and a lifelong voter I was wondering
what can I tell friends who have no
interest in voting what do I tell them
how do I convince others that they need
to vote this is a whole topic but my
strategy that I anecdotally believe is
the most effective is to explain to
people if you're opting out because you
don't think your vote makes a difference
you're actually helping someone by not
voting not voting is an active decision
and you're still making the decision by
not voting it just may not be the
decision you want to be making when you
opt out you are not saying I and you
might be thinking that you're saying I
dislike every candidate so I'm not
participating but you are still helping
one candidate over another when you
choose not to vote and most importantly
about not voters if everybody who had
this thought my vote doesn't matter so
I'm going to stay home if all of those
people didn't stay home as a group their
votes would now very much matter and
would be powerful enough to flip
elections that's what I found most
effective to talk to non voters but most
importantly make sure that they know
you're still choosing when you don't
vote and you might be choosing for the
person you you like the least
to be actually the one elected I've made
some progress with that argument with
with small groups of people we've got a
great bonus show for you today don't
miss it don't miss it david pakman.com
slash membership get a membership and
get instant access we'll see you then